brandon shot a little tired a little
tired got yeah very little sleep
woke up at two-year time correct yep i
can't sleep and here's my thing though
it's that sucks but i can't sleep in a
hotel's period like on the road
have you ever stayed in a hotel with me
never yeah we did which one uh miami
oh that's right we have it yeah we can't
sleep in hotels so here's what daddy
said
i only do airbnb's daddy take da daddy
takes the temperature down
covers his eyes covers his eyes makes
that room super black
now i'm gonna wake up now i've realized
and resigned myself the fact i'm gonna
wake up about four in the morning
my my head are racing you know your head
starts erasing you start thinking about
all the things
yeah you're gonna die one day all that
[ __ ] and then i just i wait that out
i wait it out and then i go back to
sleep you fall back part of my rem sleep
it's part of my cycle you understand
where did you where did you stay in uh
where you at i was at i was like
i was in a courtyard area he tried to
hate on me
but that was the best well he said i'm
at a dope ass
courtyard and courtyards don't go
together dude that town
like not only white but just like it's
just boring
really the shows the shows were fun
small towns shows were great
i like skyline small but like like put
it this way they just got a chick-fil-a
hell yeah they just gotta pop out it's
the middle of nowhere and a lot of
people they wear those uh
sandals the um what are those velcro
styles
is that what they call them stevia right
like those old like like you look like
you would go on like a i don't know
like the velcro yeah like that
a grateful dead concert in that yeah a
lot of the they're a lot of the on
venice though too
oh really yeah those are i haven't seen
those in like since like the 90s those
are for dads that have given up
no but the dads weren't wearing them the
kids are everybody yeah
everybody not just dads everybody's
wearing it it's when you walk
where the crowds crunk the crap
no not crunk but you gotta go back now
don't
bring your bridges no no no no you're
probably doing the hard work
they gave me some fun facts uh houdini
is
from appleton i mean that's a fun fact
you know from appleton wisconsin well i
i don't know that map changing
that's what they told me i don't believe
it no houdini he died out here
yeah right off sunset his house is uh
right in the hills yeah
he got punched in his stomach
yeah he uh he's got a restaurant there
wow but he
but he claims he claims appleton
wisconsin i guess it's what they were
saying that was their biggest thing
that they told me that was all the
information he's italian right was that
no no uh
but he's not italian and he has that
weird house up in the hills there
yeah he's like a weird thing underneath
the house he's actually from and he's
from he was born in budapest hungary
okay
yeah yep he's wearing yep and then uh
but okay
oh his family moved there when he's a
kid so yeah he's from there dude
oh okay then yeah he was jewish who dna
was jewish
huh but that was like the the the most
exciting thing kind of a big deal
yeah we we i've walked you know quite a
few trails
they got some trails you could walk was
there like one like main street and
that's it
uh it's not like that there's i think
they said there's like 70
70 000 people there but but it's still
very small yeah and they're big oh they
told me about this gas station i had to
go to called quick drip
and it was and i was like yeah they have
like chili or something man i
went in there and walked out it wasn't
that impressive i already got some
houdini gear dude
no i don't even know who's in here
justin got some brewers gear though they
had they had a that's fine i got a mall
i saw the picture the mall was like they
had like 14 people in that mall
but you go to hotel emma you don't have
to go anywhere else i don't know why i
remember
the car what is that like it was an
older building about it
it was an oil it was an old brewery
though so the when you get in there it's
made of stone
the way they made [ __ ] back in the day
and the fixtures are all brass
everything's kind of like it's kind of
like europe it's like stepping into
europe in a weird way but anybody but
even different
like uh like western industrial like
because i saw the picture you posted the
picture you posted it looked like an
older building
no uh well some of the outside is but
inside's all new
oh got it that's hot but i think the
actual building was
oh yeah it's not building yes it's
absolutely but they completely redid
yeah
i mean they did an amazing job it might
be in some ways i've stayed in
some nice hotels all over the place oh
i've been everywhere that might be the
best hotel i've ever stayed at i'm
telling you dude and the way it
beats four seasons it beats ritz carlton
it's life it's the only one
yeah it's unbelievable great food wait
the crowds in san antonio did you try
the
crowds in santa because they're they're
[ __ ] always awesome did you try the
coffee
i did try the coffee and i drank the
coffee it's not sour anymore is it
well the they have two options so the
the coffee that i got the hotel's not
sour
the coffee i get at that shop but the
one where you get the hotel's not sour
you know why because because you had a
little talk with him mm-hmm
okay that's interesting because it's not
sour it's not sauerkraut you and i have
a problem with that designer
i go there and i get an espresso and i
it's it's like it's like drinking
lemonade
yeah oh it's like a sour apple yeah
because they don't roast the bean all
the way yeah it's the new thing it's
cool
it's actually that's the new thing it's
more caffeinated
oh god it's so good i'm here for flavor
man yeah flavor
that's why you drink the coffee now let
can we talk for a second about
the elf in the room which was this
sunday i know you've talked about it no
go ahead yeah what do you got
i mean you were surprised you right well
my takeaway is this
the the logan paul came in in as you
watch it correct you don't watch
highlights
all right yeah he came in in the best
shape
like you could be yeah first of all
second of all you know
he has a work ethic right so he
obviously worked his ass off
to be ready for whatever rounds yeah
and he's also [ __ ] huge he's also
huge and he
he didn't necessarily you know he
connected a couple times more than most
a lot of most great fighters have done
to floyd he killed he landed
yeah but for the most part it was less
he can take a shot too
yeah he took he took a couple of his
legs gave out there for a second yeah i
was when i watched it
i didn't i didn't see that i'm talking
like if man i would like
if floyd wasn't there he would have
found if he's the ring
i'm here i would like i'm looking up
like this oh yeah
real quick he's got his legs yeah his
legs went and then he was like and then
floyd like grabbed them it was like
trying to dirt i'm like oh floyd
backs up he might but you know he
recovered
yeah i just impressed with this yeah i
think the biggest takeaway too is
you know floyd especially seeing him in
person floyd look 44 years old
like his timing's not there no like the
timing he was off and then
a mixture of him being 44 timings off
power's not there the quickness in there
logan paul's way bigger
so if you know the score granted the
score wasn't judged but if it was floyd
won the fight
but my point when i say logan won i mean
he won for
what his agenda was he didn't get
finished he looked
like a boxer and have you ever seen like
if you go on any gym in the world
guy have you ever seen a guy with two
fights fight it's a
it's a [ __ ] show yeah yeah dude logan
only has two feet
he did a great job i mean he looked like
a box he did damn and i'll tell he
he really did he's a very good athlete
but here's the other thing i
i i said and i maybe maybe i'll get take
heed for this from what i
saw it looked like it looked like uh um
floyd was trying to knock him out was
actually trying to connect and knock him
out yeah so the
the first the first three like so i was
around
logan's team like his parents his whole
team and his like after the first second
i think even third
his team would turn around go that's one
in the bank that's when the bank and i
kept
i didn't say this to them i was talking
my my boy steve farhood
who scores the fights i went man they
don't realize floyd's
giving him these he's letting him he's
hoping he wears out like this isn't
really floyd here
i was like fourth fifth and six he's
gonna turn on the heat
sure enough and you notice floyd wasn't
just on his back foot doing
floyd gave him no downtime yeah like it
came out
the ref would separate him and floyd
just keep going he's trying to just
melt and melt and melt them floyd was
banking on him getting gassed out then
finishing him
so then fourth fifth as soon as the
fourth round looks i look at steve i go
here we go this is this is when the
fight well this is if he's gonna get
finished it's gonna be
four or five or six four five six come
floyd lands some huge shots wobbles his
legs
logan's not going anywhere yeah
he's too big and floyd's too old it's
also a big deal to be able to take those
shots and keep your eyes open like he
would go bam and he was right there
most people don't do that you get hit
like that you back up
you get gun shy you keep it you you know
he just kept his eyes open boom and he
was there and
i'm telling you how long he's how long
has he been boxing ten minutes three
years
yeah so they're both three years yeah
same time yeah
yeah okay but they're just they i think
part of it also is
from what i understand i think logan was
a very good high school wrestler like a
really good one
yeah but even that i mean okay no but
i'm just saying but you know what i'm
saying okay there's a there's a work
ethic
it's it's not even that take all that
out of it there's a million people are
good at wrestling
literally you're not good at boxing high
school who gives a flying yeah right the
different
to me the craziest thing about all this
is when i went in this locker room i
figured
there did you know i've been tons of
locker rooms people are scared people
are warming up
it's hostile everyone's aggravated
everyone's doing work there's tension in
the room
dude i walked down the locker room you
would thought it was a restoration
hardware there was
i swear to god no b i'm not trying to be
funny they were playing
zen music oh and i walk in i'm like what
the [ __ ] is this i'm gonna go what the
[ __ ] are they doing
when i say that kid doesn't give a [ __ ]
i'm telling you man yeah nothing gets
done yeah and i'll see him on the plane
right i'm like how's he so
chill like he's fighting floyd
mayweather and he's literally goofing
around with me we're talking about
podcast [ __ ] and uh i've seen him on the
plane writer it's because he grew up
with cameras in his face since he was
10.
so the pressure of people judging him
and stuff like that
none of that matters to them like the
moment cannot get big enough when he
gets there there's not a big enough
moment for him what's he doing at ten
youtube youtube stuff oh they started
that early yeah come on i didn't know
that i'm really big big youtuber yeah
oh that's why he's so big one of the
yeah yeah but so he's like for him it's
like
the moment like you can't get big enough
like there's not a stage
big enough for him yeah so for him he's
like he's 40 and he's like he's 44
regular
he's small you know it's like yeah looks
like he'll put any gifts
and he said he's like dude i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm telling you dude
i've already won i'm like that's a great
way to put it i'm like i've
i've never seen anybody ever in my life
in any sports be this calm
i like that he's hinting even in the
ring even in the ring yeah he was like
he's looking at me going
all right dude floyd well he's smiling
he's talking to him did you hear what he
was saying dude he's like you don't care
what was he saying to him
she's talking [ __ ] yeah you can see him
this is it oh wow this is it oh he can't
talk saying that yeah he's going this is
it i was like dude
damn didn't care after the fight you see
the video i posted
yeah well you went to the locker room
i'm like i thought
champagne pie yeah yeah dude you went
eight rounds of the best [ __ ] box of
all time he goes i know crazy right they
go
i need more energy out of here yeah and
i look dragon what's wrong with her when
they go what we thought this was going
to happen like
okay man this is not annoying how are
you guys not crunk yeah
is it oh it's that big that top left
yeah i went correct that beeline
straight for the locker room
what the [ __ ] brandon
look at him i don't know what no no it's
not
this is [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] alien he
was crying that's what he said
here's what's crazy that so that that so
the first two he's feeling out
that fourth fifth and sixty that's the
best he has trying to take you out i'm
[ __ ] chill
i'm real you guys should be [ __ ]
stoked i don't know what to do bro he's
not jealous
he's just chilling yeah i mean doesn't
care [ __ ] i mean
hey doesn't care it's crazy [ __ ] it
i think people are getting confused so
when i say he won the he did he didn't
win the
fight he won the game no thank you he
beat the game yes
100 he did what are you talking about
he did kind of what none of us thought
he was ever going to be able to do
people are so stupid
yeah they're so stupid yeah it's it's
it's got one in every facet
yeah it's kind of the american story
but people are upset but they're upset
like it shouldn't like
he's a glitch in the system like no he
can't he has no hair boxing experience
but he came prepared what do you mean
like you're saying it's a glitch
like a youtuber with whatever six
million followers
shouldn't be able technically to get in
there and survive any round well here's
why here's my
buddy if you watch him with krs-1 or
whatever that guy's name is
k-k-s paris one's a rapper
where is
so yeah so if you're basing the
performance
going into the fight based off logan's
last fight against ksi
and based off floyd's last fight against
connor you're like man
logan's [ __ ] right but no logan got
way better
yes floyd age you gotta remember he
fought conor in 2017
that's five years ago so going from 39
to 44 is a
lifetime of a difference in the fight
game and it's also you know it's not
floyd firing all cylinders and like
wanting this right it was him being like
out beat the [ __ ] yeah he's just like
[ __ ]
both of them were just like yeah i think
floyd was like uh he
i think he announced he's like i'm not
doing any more of these no not and
i think also there is size does make a
big difference man that's it it made a
difference in this one where he can eat
his shots
like if he's any smaller you probably
would have put him down but i mean he
lands a big shot
logan wants to actually become a boxer
right no he said that he's finding
someone's interview he goes he goes so
is your goal to become like
cruiserweight champions what
no he goes i don't want to do that [ __ ]
he goes no michael's to be the biggest
entertainer in the world this is just a
stopping
yeah which is exact that's this is my
point of view
my joke that was i was like if you want
to become if you want to become a
professional boxer and make a buck load
of money
you you you want to spend a little bit
of time boxing a lot of time doing
youtube videos
yeah once we're sick but but he's he
again though like you said he
he is talented he is athletic he is a
very good athlete
i mean look at that there's no way he
did look like a boxer he did yeah
now jake's a different animal jake's on
a different path you know he's fighting
woodley that's the difference he wants
to fight
he wants the fight fight yeah and him
woodley's a fight that's a good fight
that's going to be interesting yeah yeah
what's your call on that
i don't know i don't know good fight
depends how much woodley wants to be in
there
yeah yeah
how was it interviewing them it was cool
it was a lot of hurry up and wait
you know oh yeah it's annoying yeah and
then the rain effect with everything
that's so much
your temperament you know it's good if
you're good at it i thought that you're
like
no i was logan was funny we were all
laughing yeah
it's just like uh the the rain like my
job was
you know i was like the logan specialist
and then i was gonna do
like funny things with all the
celebrities in the crowd like
we had tom brady cardi b like all these
big celebrities we're gonna
chime in with and before the main event
and then the rain came
yeah celebrities melting rain so then
[Laughter]
because they're you know so it pushed
everything back so then
yeah you know on the headset like we got
to cut the celebrity interviews like oh
that's cool i didn't see the ochocinco i
only saw him get knocked out
he didn't get knocked out he got knocked
down
but he was winning the entire fight just
caught with that one really yeah he
looked good
really he was [ __ ] him up he just got
i don't know he's in his 40s yeah he
didn't look bad though and i thought it
was a bad fight for him
he's a crazy athlete man so yeah 43.
it's very damn
i don't like the picture they use of him
it could be anybody
come on google [ __ ] wow there he is
now was that was that a money player i
think just a challenge he doesn't need
money and he didn't make a ton either no
i think it's just a challenge for him he
looked pretty good he even said he's
like i just want to see what it's about
i'm one and done this isn't like a
career yeah no he's i just want to feel
what it was like
that's not something i want to feel what
it's like yeah i don't get it either i
could never do that
i want a box oh i felt so bad on the on
the early early prelims
they have this kid who's from uh tmt so
floyd miller's team yeah this
monster they're lighter weights but just
this monster and they just brought in
this
this kid probably just got done rolling
tortillas oh
no no no no he's huge no no he's on the
prelims oh okay
this he's fighting some young floyd
mayor of the prospect and
the kid walks in says sweet gear on
you're like oh god obviously
this poor mexican's being set up shitty
body
look like you just got done rolling
tortillas oh and you see him in there
and he's just like
like obviously in there to get
annihilated but he's kind of giving it
all he can i'm like okay here he goes
and i'm literally i'm i'm with i'm
sitting the kid's getting knocked out
where chappelle is
and i see him go go and then
right in front of me but that was the
same eyes open just like yeah
well bottom bottom jack was being made
no money yeah
that's the real boxer right there yeah
right take care of business jonathan
gray
0-4 now what yeah writing out for him
why'd they give him a non-boxer
i felt so bad for him well no he's a
bodybuilder they give you a little
job got it
dude it was you're just like i was here
and then you know the kid made
that's the guy he fought no
oh it must be no someone late
replacement that guy did not look like
that
i'm telling you it looked like the guy
just made somebody's quesadilla like hey
you want to fight he's like yeah [ __ ] it
hold my apron
dude and it made zero dollars i felt so
bad oh my god you couldn't make the
count either it can make the tank count
they stand on me just like well so a lot
of those exhibition fights were just
for fun like no money no nothing just
just that's so that's a pro fight robot
yeah
that that was that that's a real
execution fights yeah
and i don't think it's weird when they
mix them like i felt bad for
like uh heard what's his name um
hurt i felt bad for that that was like
were you at that fight that was yeah
brutal brutal he takes supposed to win
that fight for boto
boto jack you know former champ like
those guys it's not gonna
i don't think it does them any favors
being on those celebrity fights like
keep them in the real
yeah yeah well visibility maybe i don't
know
no it's not translating it's all youtube
how was that fight was is jared heard
actually fighting at 54 was that at one
point well he was supposed to fight uh
pascal and then he's huge gal tested hot
for every steroid
and was like what i can't do that like
no he's like oh my bad like you can't
fight
i don't know how jared hurd fights at
that weight he looks so much bigger than
that i haven't seen him in person i
think he was 160 for this fight
he was like something right for what
175. not that big of a guy yeah
damn that guy put it up yeah that was a
fight fight
stud yep how's
uh our boy stevie doing get some guys
lids done
uh he actually didn't we went to the
doctor's office
and when we got there they looked at his
eye and said that the sky needs to
calcify more and harden before they can
actually remove it
so they injected him with a bunch of
fluid to try to flush it out
they said he needs to come back in a
month if it doesn't get better then they
need to cut it out
did they flush it out or no no they uh
injected
it with liquid which then it'll take
about a month to see if it does flush
so you're going to have this for like
two months so why is it what just got it
just got
infected that area and it just so he's
very prone to getting styes he said
he's had it throughout his entire life
do they know why uh he just
produces a lot of oil that tends to get
infected very easily around his eyes
it's just something with the hurt and
it's so bad your head has stein right
i mean you're like i was like yeah they
hurt
a kid god they heard they're so
sensitive too
but i've never i've never gotten like a
crazy crazy one does he wear contacts or
no uh no he doesn't
they're they they hurt so [ __ ] bad oh
yeah yeah
yes he has to just deal with that yeah
next two months
uh now he has to have like a specific
eye washing regimen every morning but
i'll say hey doc
[ __ ] anything else that i have to
wait for two months while the water you
shot on my
body are we in 2001 how about some
[ __ ] science but also he thought he
was going in and get it fixed
and yeah he can't do it yeah he that's
what he thought too
and then the doctor said oh i thought
your style was going to calcify at this
point but it's not really
oh really because i was here last week
he was texting me while he was in the
exam room they didn't let me in
and so he's texting me like well i guess
i'm going to get a needle in my eyelid
oh she's getting cauliflower eyelid yeah
you got to wait till that and then you
gotta cut it out they gotta cut it
off yeah if it doesn't flush out they
then open up his eyelid and then like
basically scrape it off
but it's a it's a lot smaller than what
it was it's a lot smaller than what it
was
it's like a he tiny little thinger is he
okay
he's currently in pain because he had a
needle in his eyelid but
generally he's fine i guess as fine as
you can be
does he have to be awake for the surgery
or no uh for the surgery i'm not sure
what they did was they put numbing cream
on his eye today
and then that's how they put the needle
in i think he might have to be awake
but i'm not worshipping a patch he does
have an eye patch at home oh he does
yeah oh hell yeah
yeah and well he's got a beard he's got
long hair
with his eye patch he's going to look
like a really funny yells i sell drugs
like an eye patch
he looks right one guy that pete
davidson made fun of on snl
do you remember that politician on snl
that
he gave us yes he looks like him now
christian's a badass yeah he's a good
looking wait that's that is not him
dan crenshaw christian he's it was like
dave christian who did
dance
that's a good looking villain he looks
like everybody
i have an eye patch though there like
you just like rock the old one now it's
just like this weird
implant thing i prefer the strap yeah
need to
odd strap all day yeah he kind of looks
like russell crowe in that one he does
he does from unhinged yes he does
that's kind of a plumber you got one
[ __ ] eye the height he has now is
kind of dope
it's like a marble type thing and it has
a
trident on it so it's a marine driver
that's [ __ ] let's get away i have no
idea it's like it's
dark uh it's like deep blue and then the
trident was gold
it looked sick oh it's dave there's your
boy dave prince show well david
i already have an issue with yeah you
don't [ __ ] with those motivations
i'll tell you something whenever they
they do this
book the results yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah brian read it clearly yeah what did
you do oh you haven't done anything but
you
oh here you go you have a business of
being a motivational author speaker and
online trainer
building productive leaders united
builder when he's cooking diagnosed with
adhd who's not dude wow man i
just we're just hanging on they've got
sharks
i i live in l.a so what i've seen time
and again is what happens is people
hustle they come to be actors now things
don't work out
it's a tough gig so what happens is you
have a
you have what's called a mental
breakdown
no i'm not trying to be a dick so when
you have a mental breakdown you go and
buy a suit
so when you look at you then you turn on
the youtube camera you're looking here
and you're 40 and and
and you go it's actually not going to
work out i'm not going to be emailing
you
the whole dream board my goal sheet
ain't going to work out now
you got a choice you can either die you
can either just
jump right the [ __ ] out the window move
to new mexico or you can say
i got to learn how to get through this
yeah i'm going to read some books on how
to do this and get through it
and what you do is you convince yourself
that it's going to be all right and then
you become
an influence a life yeah i was i'm
always curious i'm like who
like like what gave them that now
michael jordan released five steps i'm
reading that
i'm reading the book but it's a lot of
these people slap dick with all that
botox and a bad suit it's like this is
my five steps
to success yeah i mean it's i don't know
who that guy's i don't want to be mean
but there are no you're not you don't
mean me but like i
give you they're all calling artists
they're all they're all just trying to
shift the system and like trying to make
a budget it gives you this
it gives you an icky feeling i just
don't think you ever
accomplish anything or get actually what
you want done
with five easy steps with a saying
with an inspirational quote i don't
believe
put your ideas on a perhaps list to
promote creative thinking in a
manageable way
the more simple the email the higher
chance of getting a response goals
without a plan are just wishes the more
simple the email the higher chance of
getting a response oh my god thank god
dude i'm glad i read this want to show
someone you care
give them your attention yeah i hate
these
i hate these [ __ ] rules i this is
what you do
it's very basic well yeah this is how
you sell it but it's also like
obviously yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying
go up click on the one that goes there
if you care give them attention how many
likes does that have
if you can it was higher no no no no
right below someone you care gives me
your attention
i got it yep 28 likes that's what you
get and that was february 3rd
he says have you ever had someone stare
at their phone tapping away on the
screen while listening to you
how did that make you feel now you're
now for a tougher question how many
times have you been the one
switch task on a person who's talking to
you i get it i literally wrote the book
on this
but i still do it too sometimes give
people your full attention
all right right people deserve our full
attention no they don't
most of the time 98
this is the thing i i don't know
honestly like i don't know if there are
any shortcuts
like i i think it takes a really long
time
to get good at something like i i don't
care who your agent is i don't care who
the
you're you're either like to be a really
good stand-up comic
that the challenge never goes away oh
it's a really good boxer to be a really
good piano player i mean i'll see you in
10 years and you better be practicing
all the time yeah
you know there yeah there's there's no
shortcut no shortcuts well
dave crenshaw makes a difference dave
this is a five-step program for 49.99 a
month
i think i think of it as a high-tech
procrastination so i watched tony
robbins
like knows he's the real deal though
he's the real deal but okay he's big
he's like the big the biggest but when
he has those the most when he has those
seminars i've watched and i'm not your
guru it's a really good documentary but
what i saw was a bunch of dudes who were
they're building themselves up and we
can do this and you change your mindset
and it's positive affirmation
thinking to me that's high-tech
procrastination i don't give a [ __ ]
about
believing in myself i never believe in
myself you know what makes me believe
myself when i get good at something then
i can believe myself
yeah just do the [ __ ] work learn how
to do something and you'll get closer
are you pitching a motivational book now
yeah now i'm annoyed about it yeah yeah
the book says you know what my book says
yeah one page ready it's just forever
it just takes forever takes forever yeah
it takes forever and and
practice every day and you might still
not make it yeah
and when you get there it won't feel
like you're there
it's about i've said this i've said this
before my my success feels like like
when i
at one point two tv shows [ __ ] big
podcast
stand up and somebody said well but it
was like somebody was like you got so
successful what's your what's your
secret
do you have any advice for
i've been doing this for 26 years like
26 years it's so long like and i said
it's the equivalent of throwing a rock
at a sparrow every time it flies by my
[ __ ] doorway
if i did that for 25 years every day all
day i'd hit some sparrows i'd get some
sparrows knock him out of the [ __ ]
sky
that's that's doesn't mean i'm a good
rock thrower just means i threw the
[ __ ]
rocks at every sparrow that came by so
it's just that i don't know
you throwing a [ __ ] [ __ ] on the wall
some of it's going to stick
yeah you get seven yeses in in one
million those
all right it's not even that it's just
just but that tony robbins stuff works
for people more power to you man
you know what i mean
you know the one thing i listen to
everything he did because i was writing
a tv show on a self-help guru
okay okay and i wanted to make fun of
him and i got sucked in do you know the
one thing i got from his thing that i
can remember that i still think about it
tony robbins yeah he said
he said one is he's very big on setting
goals right specific goals writing him
down
but he said the main thing i heard was
he said change
your primary question i was like what
the [ __ ] that mean he goes
most people have a question in their
mind that's not helpful it's a question
like am i good enough
am i lovable will i make it it's a
[ __ ] question right i'm out but he
said
reprogram your brain to ask a better
question so what do i have to do today
to get closer to my goal
or something like that or who what do i
want what would i ask for if i knew i
couldn't fail
so he has these questions that that
makes sense yeah that got you you're
asking yourself
a question not a [ __ ] negative
question that doesn't have a good answer
to it
yeah so change the primary question like
how how do i get into this
how do i get in at this comedy club
which is not a little whatever it is
like like but that's all i remember but
sometimes
i think in a way my default was always
kind of like
it's not that hard to see what you want
right like if you start something like
when you join the ufc you're like i want
to be a champion that's not that
complicated you just
you figure out who you have to train
with pretty complicated no it's hard
i'm not saying i'm saying setting a goal
is not complicated like you said
but then you go well what do i have to
do but that's those people's problems
aren't their goals
they they don't know what they want they
don't know yeah they're professional
athletes that's not
no professional athlete has a issue
going i don't know what i want
yeah that's why you turn to tony robbins
you don't know what you want you don't
if you did you won't be buying his books
you'd be doing here
hey some people are probably successful
they can't if it helps more power too
long you'll [ __ ] get into satanism
i think that's what motivates you more
power to you man i think getting good at
anything
is a good way to get to the next thing
like learning
how this turned into motivation which
drives me
absolutely bonkers i know it's driving
me doing it and i'm like hey look
it's like mine is just probably like i
hate this [ __ ] that mine's like it's one
step at a time
people ask me how did you do it and i'm
like you just gotta
start i'm like oh my god now you're
doing what [ __ ] dave fitzgerald's
doing
i am a little bit happy so it's
exhausting i'm a little better than you
about the same come on dude
did you see his followers hold on ready
change ready ready
change the primary question in your
brain and it takes forever
go for free change the question
write that down write that down change
the question
you don't like you don't like
inspirational quotes oh my gosh just go
man let's go just do it go
i like makeup i'm sorry i was thinking
about it make up those
pick up your own inspirational
let me hear you make up your own
inspirational quote you have five
seconds oh [ __ ] come on you have to
do it one yeah [ __ ] do it
do it yeah that's it yeah that's not a
nike's thing dude
but that's what i said [ __ ] do it
just [ __ ]
do
go ahead do the thing you're talking
about when you're like yeah someone came
up to me and you're trying to humbly
brag
how do you deal with all this stuff do
that because that never happened
do that dude it did too that never
happened people ask me
um go ahead and ask me ask me like
what's uh one motivational thing
how'd you get a tesla no no no wait ask
how chappelle i don't like your attitude
you're on i can't help you hey you yeah
yeah
yeah he's the [ __ ] giant with a bad
ass you come out of this get him out
he's gonna kick me out of the
separate yourself from people who are
not helpful to your goals that should be
the first one yeah yeah
he's being too real yeah i swear to god
though
what i say about acting most acting
classes you're going back
this way to what a teacher should say
most of the time i go like this i go
hey listen quit hey
that that doesn't hear people because
even even in college i remember where
the nfl scout
comes he goes how many guys seem to make
the nfl stand up
everybody stands because four of you in
this room will make it everyone's like
yeah whatever like you don't change
yeah you're like well i'll be one of the
four percentage actually the best thing
you could do is go you're never gonna
make it and then people go
[ __ ] something you'll be like [ __ ] you
yeah give him a chip maybe a chip's the
best thing
sometimes you need to i know a lot of
successful people that work from that
a lot chip on the shoulder yes who are
trying to improve people
that might be the best way the best way
to go you open the book and it just says
you suck you don't have every day it
should just talk [ __ ] to you yes
yes some people have it all internet
will do that for you read your comments
that'll do it for you yeah
that'd give you a massive if you want a
chip just go on there let's feel
i had an acting teacher with my favorite
he just goes he looks to the class and
he goes
scare yourself that's your son oh no
jumping i don't know did you do it
sure didn't sure did it i was too
[ __ ]
worried yeah i was worried enough about
failing you took a lot of acting classes
yeah for 10 years dude oh
i worked really hard at acting really
hard and then came to the conclusion
i don't like it you didn't like it it
took you 10 years to realize that though
oh no i learned wait now
see what happens you just stuck with it
denial yes
call denial people get divorced with
somebody after 20 years over what they
knew about the person in the first five
minutes
the rest is denial denial we're just
like no i got to be i came here to be an
actor someone really
i worked so hard but i don't like it
that's the truth i can finally say it oh
is it the hours oh you're exhausted no
i'm good i just i don't do the
motivational stuff but i'm listening
okay i'm listening he's back and forth
he she checks in check
check check in check out he's there no
because i think you're right i think
ultimately you're right i think the
motivational stuff is just
yeah just what you can just do high-tech
procrastination yeah
would you this weekend chin summer is
almost here
kids and it's father's day that's right
it's coming up go to omahastakes.com
type in
fighter in the search bar and order dad
the get out and grill assortment pack
right now we're talking about 20 entrees
he's guaranteed to love the ultra juicy
burgers
the plump juicy chicken desserts four
10-ounce butcher cuts new york strips
these strips are aged
30 days so they're super tender
plus you get four free new york strip
burgers with your order
these are ultra lean and packed with
bold intense flavor
for your dad's mouth all right oma
steaks isn't just steaks it's the best
steaks ever
guaranteed my favorite thing about this
get out and grill assortment
one thing i know my papa's gonna love i
love their new york strip burgers i make
them thick
juicy put a little cheddar cheese on
them they're my favorite thing out of
this package
so get your dad the perfect gift the get
out and grill assortment right now
get out and grill assortment right now
all you got to do is visit
omahastakes.com
keyword fighter and send your dad
something he will love
don't forget for a limited time you get
four free new york strip burgers with
your order that's omahastakes.com
keyword fighter
today's low interest rates is a great
time to refinance your student loans
earnest offers low rate student loan
refinancing
you can check your rate risk free in
just two minutes with earnest
you get flexible payments you can pick
your loan term
by refinancing can reduce your loan term
save money or combine multiple loans
in a simple monthly payment if you have
any questions you can even talk to a
real human
at earnest for help all right isn't it
time you stop feeling overwhelmed by
your student debt
earnest is offering you guys a hundred
dollars cash bonus refinance your
student debt
earnest dot com slash fighter terms
condition apply
once again you get a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you visit earnest.com
fighter to refinance your student loan
no
available in all states can't get
everywhere terms conditions why
visit earnest.com fighter for more
details
terms conditions apply student loan
refinance made by earnest operations llc
and mls number nine one seven california
financing law license number six zero
five four seven eight eight
three or three seconds street suite 401
north san francisco california
94107 visit earnest.com license for full
list of licenses
that is a hundred dollar cash bonus when
you visit earnest.com
fighter what did i do i got the jeremy
lin uh
uh elbow bracelet it's on the other side
though right hey are you doing the head
and all right are you doing the back
exercises like videotaping
i was gonna bring that up so i did this
over the weekend too so brian sent me
like a series of different videos that
he recorded he had someone actually
record him
all these different poses and they're
like minutes long each video he's like
chin
do this do this and it's actually
helping helping with yeah
stuff yeah the towel to the head doing
this that's helpful these are cars those
are [ __ ] good so
is your back feeling better a little bit
better you got to keep doing it i got to
keep doing it yeah
you know you liked it though it was uh
well i felt like it was two times my
muscles were really really working so
yeah yeah
i was i was hoping you'd do it three
days three times until you did that yeah
just do it
i told you i got exhausted the first
time i did it that's okay but it's not
that hard
three days man you'll give me three days
it's only
like some k like i dare you basically
i'm sure i have the video somewhere i
could pop it up oh you gotta realize i
was a cheerleader oh never mind
you're good what'd you do cat um on
saturday i did a shoot with
uh the guys from just kidding uh the
just kidding films family i did jk news
and then i had only fan shoot right
after today i'm sorry
i'm sorry all right remember when you
were joking about shoots
right what motivational book did you
read right
i did an interview where they asked me
how i was so successful
but it's a photo shoot for your only
fans yeah because i'm finding that it
just
it's easier for me now to take a day
like
once every two weeks to load up on
content so i can slowly
pace it out and post just because like
it's not realistic for me to keep doing
it by myself day after day because [ __ ]
gets monotonous
now do you do you have to get creative
with it yeah but like it's not like a
fancy shoot either i either she was like
friends or
on saturday my sister was my
photographer because i haven't seen
stevie get good with the camera what the
[ __ ]
okay here's the thing because i am so
[ __ ] awkward when it comes to stuff
like that i can only really shoot in
front of
people you don't know people yeah people
i either don't know like a girl or my
sister because my sister
yeah i'm super comfortable with stevie
also doesn't know how to use a camera
properly and i don't have the heart to
tell him
because he's offered and i'm like oh no
i don't have the heart to tell him he
takes terrible good dad like he can edit
and stuff he can do some stuff yes
photoshopping and editing great however
he holds a camera like
a middle-aged father like with the dslr
he's holding it with like one hand
imagine one of these cameras he's
holding it with one hand like this
now are you doing are you doing more
than your feet oh yeah uh yeah i
will post anything you can see on
instagram basically oh okay so i don't
do nudity but anything like a ig model
does online i'll post on there
yeah have they asked you to step it up
you had to be like
why don't we just take that top off for
this time oh yeah but
people have been asking me this since
they found my instagram account oh
fans are asking but i'm saying it
doesn't even before only fans oh no
photographer like why don't we uh
no pants no ditch the pants see this is
why i shoot with them
right this is why i shoot a bling
mustache it's james frank's french girl
it's james franco yeah that's a funny
thing
yeah it's a little heavy huh seems like
this is hot in here huh
do you feel like you're in a jail from
the waist down don't we ditch the pants
we're just
is your lower body american you might
want to let it let it free what does
that mean
doesn't want to breathe
i get it but that's the page if you're
keeping your legs here in other reasons
in cuba
i mean we're freeing out this isn't
north korea this isn't north korea
let's get the tits out
how do you feel about that hey stephen
you're big dick stevie right
why don't you get in there man once you
ditch your
hit me up on only fans trying to see
stevie's dick is insane
oh they want to see this there are
people well one like you can see his
dick
online behind it they can't find it more
than i want to
it's people who want to see like his
dick and then like
to comparison like my arm yeah what yeah
a lot of people want to see
tv was the guy's name be shot 101.
i didn't want to put it out there but
yes
i think this is brandon that'd be sick
she sees your tattoo hanging out
he keeps telling him stephen somebody
else's account is big gay owl 202.
yeah yeah i don't know what you're
talking about i don't know
it gets really quiet what's my name
yours
uh i don't know something with backflips
probably oh okay yeah oasis
steve stevie he's got a world
world-class
piece yes no he's making money off of it
for god's sake
let me be him he's very adamant about
being retired because i'll throw ideas
at him i'm like okay i don't know you'll
be open to it you're like hey i was
talking to the person
if somebody wants if somebody wants a
photo of just his dick which people have
asked me for just his dick like nothing
to do with me
i asked him like hey if you want me to
send this picture i'll give you whatever
it is they paid for it
and he's like no he's very adamant oh he
didn't he don't he don't wonder
he gets he's more of a prude well i
wonder if that would turn off your face
they're asking for no there's certain
people who ask for it so i wouldn't put
it out there to the masses it's just the
people who requested you
put his dick in situations like you know
what i wanted
to do i would draw i put a mustache on
the front i put like different mustaches
yeah
it'd be like a little hitler i put a
little hat on it like snake or stevie's
dick
draw
in disguise he's just kind of like
hanging out on a plane
no it's like a where's waldo they got to
find it in the picture
yeah yeah you get arrested he's like i
would do more of the puppet like costume
stuff
oh yeah you want it out yeah i put like
a little ear like bunny ears on
you that would be adorable
that they sold at urban outfitters for a
while it was called like the
dick pokey where like you put your dick
through a book and it has like different
uh backgrounds for it so it looks like a
dinosaur elephant
oh that crosses the line i need to dress
up stevie's actual thing
no yeah you put your actual dick in it
yeah i know i want little hats but we
draw on and stuff
oh right monsters horns on it you gonna
draw on this dick yeah i'm down if you
want see if we can give him and then you
put like save the white rhinos yeah
that'd be sick
you could paint it oh my god but it's a
real book but yeah
i guess you do it with your girl or your
gay boy
so boring that would get so boring oh
dude after the first two i know you take
it
it's a hot dog yeah it's not a party
book really
so what if your dick gets awesome oh
god actually that's actually that's
hilarious that's [ __ ] funny
this book is fantastic is there more to
it i don't know
there we go that one's like a skinny one
christian why'd you play kickball um
no i just watched the fights really i
didn't do anything special that's nice
yeah no kickball this weekend though nah
you guys got a bye week or what
oh we do next week uh oh you really do
have a bike yeah next week we're taking
on firefighters uh
uh santa clarita fire station oh damn
yeah you're about to get your asses
yeah yeah they're uh i think they're
juicing but yeah yeah
they're big guys i don't know i don't
know if i don't know if they'll pass
like league regulation rules because we
test for it so usada y'all do yeah
hell no they don't oh i'd be first stay
down i was like bro
sorry you look like this were you bored
yesterday
listen i don't know about you guys
[ __ ] leagues it's kickboxing it's
[ __ ] kickball dog
there's a lot of cheating kickball yeah
there's a lot of doping
because you can get tired of drugs a lot
of money involved all right what do you
got jen
curtis yeah yeah all right sure
here we go okay so the group anonymous
made a video
basically saying that elon musk is
a narcissistic like egotistical maniac
who is [ __ ] with people's money
because he will come on
to the crypto sphere release some weird
tweets and then it fluctuates the market
which then
affects people who are kind of banking
on it to make money
and it's kind of just they don't say
anything necessarily threatening him but
if you get a message from anonymous
it's kind of a threat for sure yeah they
don't [ __ ] so yeah
elon musk is their current new target
so anonymous yeah they they are the
direct stuff
they're computer hackers and stuff like
that yeah that's pretty much they've
done anything to them yet or not uh they
have not
done anything yet right now they're more
so putting them on blast because they
seem like they're good
people like ultimately right have you
guys seen the movie uh
the show money heist no i watched it
over it it's on the in the forum right
yeah yeah that's a shout out
it's a ten part series i get that when
they wrap the first bank like all right
got it
we're gonna do this every [ __ ]
episode machine keeper i love money
heist
i like the first one yeah that's fair
it's like a real short uh
talent you know [ __ ] italian job yeah
they do it every episode
that oh
the main girl her name is ursula it's in
it's in subtitles
yeah because it's originally a spanish
show yeah yeah
or something she's so [ __ ] pretty she
is interesting i agree
um right there she is huh
oh you know i didn't get to sleep that's
right i got my ugly goggles out there
she's pretty yeah i think she's so brave
she's super pretty in that other one
she's pretty and all but
yeah yeah yeah she's super pretty there
she's gorgeous
yeah huh we just started on the the
borscht picture i think maybe it was
just the pictures chin hat on this one
yeah because they make her they
purposefully kind of make her a little
more butchier looking in the show
yeah i think she's outstanding yeah
she's gorgeous she's cool
she's cool this is cool just cool yeah
uh after elon musk yeah
damn that's right they're just they're
just like threatening they're saying if
you keep [ __ ] this bitcoin
yes that's basically what the video is
about tim dillon uh hosted the
so when i was in miami there was the
bitcoin community tim dillon hosted that
[ __ ] coin right
i don't know but before he went on i
guess there's some inspirational guy
crying saying how they're changing the
world
then tim gunn goes nobody should be
crying about bitcoin and just lit him up
he's like this is not your savior
like this bitcoin and just lit the
entire room updated
he's great he's gosh monster yeah he is
oh i did a set for uh with miss pat
at the miami improv oh yeah when i got
in i text
the improv manager uh troy i think
for his name but i text him like hey i'm
in town we'd love to get a set tonight
he's like yeah come down
i have no idea who is headlining who's
miss pat do you know miss pat no
she's on rogan before she's on rogan oh
i know miss pat i love miss power yeah
she's so nice yeah i love monster
i love her she's getting ready to shoot
a special friend she's so great she is
she's great yeah she was so nice she
killed me on rogan she was [ __ ]
hilarious and then i did a set with her
she's a monster yeah i realized she you
know what she's basically the female
version of joey diaz she's hilarious
she was politically so dirty yeah yes
she goes
all the way i know she has a great shot
a great story
crazy she got shot in her titty
yep what yeah by her by her ex-husband
or something like that she's crazy
yeah he shot her he shot her in the
titties she lit that room
did she talk about that on rogan i don't
know yes she did yeah i must have missed
that part she's
so nice too yeah she's so cool she's so
nice and ruthless she don't give a [ __ ]
she's a real [ __ ] cop
yeah that's a real bad female crush
yeah she lives in atlanta oh she does
yep she's shooting a special for netflix
and she has a tv show she's coming out
of the show
not not out yet it's coming out on bt
plus
[ __ ] yeah good for her she's so nice
around she's so cool show us one though
she is fun you know you know
predominantly black uh audience
and then she goes hard on white people
and then uh you know i did my thing and
then she goes how are y'all gonna cheer
for that white boy
on my [ __ ] show so who's cheering for
that white voice
just juice chair for that white boy
dressed like that what the [ __ ] are you
guys doing
you were dressed up dog yeah you had to
get
me man those were were those coochie
pants yeah
wait do you say cool too do you say
what were they made of leather no i wish
they were leather yeah i know you do
but i am a little hot for leather pants
pants in general
how hot was it there it was just like
especially when the rain came down
during that fight it was so muggy
[Music]
i could see you fighting that's some of
the best food i've ever had in my life
there really we went to the sushi place
was ridiculous really oh my gosh where'd
you stay at this time the same spot we
did
no far from it oh really i was like 30
minutes outside i stayed at
yeah there were others you can kind of
see oh okay now
now best looking people in the world
maybe they're or no dude
the ring girls i was like
hopefully i didn't show my face on tv
every time they went up to the ring like
bent over was all
it was like you're looking up at a horse
before the guy cuts your head off but
that's not what's going on
yeah they had a camera on me but then
the ring curls the green girls would get
him like hopefully
yeah that one on the left was stupid her
body was stupid
now i think um because i was looking at
uh logan next to you he's he they said
he was six
one and a half he's six three i feel
like he's definitely six
two he's not six three no i mean he's
not small though
no he looks as tall as he's ring card
girls jesus
oh the whole the entire crowd though
yeah it's some beautiful people
shiny there's a bunch of influences it
was so funny because you know it
it's different than your normal boxing
thing and all those influencers have
their camera guys there
filming and the showtimes guy is to make
sure nobody films
so he's i mean for four hours his entire
time trying to shut i'm like dude
i'm like you're not this is what these
kids do like this
they get content this is what they do
man you got to quit trying to
shut it down now bubba he's as tall as
you are
i mean i'm telling you yeah look at him
yeah well i mean every time i see you
guys next to each other he
seems to be as tall as you are but he's
up there he looks there yeah so she
there and that's six foot
four to me he's a small kid yeah i mean
he's
he's he's tall
how brilliant is it he does that fight
and then you know floyd has all his
promotional stuff but then logan what he
did is dropped his maverick athletic
line
the day of the fight so he sold [ __ ]
millions of merch
those kids know the game they know the
game they [ __ ] get it yeah
all right what else catching here we go
oh okay so this one is a sad one uh
the last white horned rhino male
has died so this is technically now an
extinct
species or extinct breed of rhino there
are only
two more i can't protect them yeah there
are only two more in the world and
they're both women
so they cannot procreate but they have
they have they have their dna span right
we got them in captivity yeah so we'll
just
get some messages it's just it's just
that one as long as they keep making
rhino horn they have so much rhino horn
on warehouses so much
rhino horn in warehouses they come they
still think it's like like a
flood the [ __ ] yeah but they flood
the market here's what you do well then
you kill a [ __ ] ton of rhinos
flood the market with all the rhino horn
that we have flood the market
just put it all out there and then put a
bunch of fake rhino horn out there
that looks they can come up with it's
just keratin it's like dude you know
yeah
and just put that out there you just
flood the market and then you breed the
[ __ ] things
the government's like we haven't thought
of that no but they haven't i was in
south africa and that's what the guys
were saying the guys were like love the
market and
while we keep trying to make it
impossible you're trying to
you're trying to [ __ ] control an area
the size of
i can't remember how big kruger park is
it's the size of israel or something
okay and you're gonna try to police that
okay you're not doing that
with with their sophisticated techniques
and rhinos are super easy to kill i
think i have some of these gray rhinos
go white face man that's paint and white
so it's 7
523 miles enjoy that squirt squad
nightmare
yeah i'm trying to so so again breed
them in captivity
actually harvest their horns and sell it
just flood the market with it you want
to educate the idiots buying it think
about
super power how about you educate them
how about we do that so there's no
market for it correct because those
horns do
nothing they do nothing they don't care
it's black magic you [ __ ] more they
just have it for
like trophy pretty much ignorance no
they think the
for chinese medicine they think of
chinese medicine cures cancer
and like well in fact one of the guys
who was remember who the african premier
was but he
he took rhino horn for his cancer and
once that happens it's like you know
so it that's just a crazy price it's
like bare gallbladder
the idea of care bear gallbladder is it
it fetches it it cures certain types of
cancer
so the myth goes so guess what people
they [ __ ]
tried to kill a bear at the zoo i think
they did they shot a beard later too
this
i think it was in fact uh and maybe some
were a korean something
they killed the bear got in there and
cut the gallbladder out
yeah and because his mom was sick or
something did she survive
she did not what if you're like she did
bend him like well we were getting some
gallbladder
bladder cures cancer yeah so you gotta
educate the people about
it it's [ __ ] stupid yeah especially
in 221
who the [ __ ] taking rhino they thought
viagra did make a bit of a thing but it
does
they thought people take took it for
sexual prowess
to actually take it more for like curing
cancer and stuff
but it doesn't work stupidity it doesn't
[ __ ] be like eating your nails yeah
doctors are like
no well no dude no oh now you don't want
to listen to doctors china
okay oh yeah yeah do that
keep eating rhino dick right i know she
got it i tell you what's wrong
dick i'll go on good no nothing
okay so a mom over in texas dressed up
as her 13 year old daughter snuck into
school
and basically like had the entire day
where she pretended to be her daughter
she ate lunch without a mask nobody
caught her
teachers principals did not catch her
wow she says that she did it
because she wanted to see how easy it
was for somebody who wasn't supposed to
be in the school
who wasn't a child to basically breach
into cover onto campus
she ended up posting a youtube video
about it i like her
she got caught at the very end only
because a teacher noticed that her phone
was out and she got in trouble for
having it
that's the only time that they noticed
that it wasn't see the set of double d
tits
also said that she said that she got
dressed up and she said she looks
nothing like her daughter that
anybody who pays attention should be
able to recognize that this is a fully
grown
middle it's middle school though and the
mom's short you know
yeah i see but she said that she uh
actually talked to
other teachers and students throughout
the day and nobody noticed
she even ate lunch without my 13 year
old for a whole day
at school she posted it on takedown
school sorry for the quality of this
video
amazing kids are mean too kids right
who's that
you know they're all talking look at
that look at the nukes and the [ __ ]
dork over there it's crazy i'm just
doing that old weathered face right
there
she's got nails like her nails are
middle schoolers can do nails though
it's her face i gave her away yeah if
she had the mask on the whole time yeah
also what does your daughter look like
you know there are certain girls who
look
very much like their parents so they
might be able to get away with it
also don't you have to work yeah what do
you think people say good job
sam tripoli showed up at uh when we were
doing conspiracy social probably showed
up with black nails
nail polish and i'm like just had black
nail polish and i was like just
she's gonna show up with black nail
polish dude like you're not a druid like
you're not a
you're not a warlock you're not what is
it what if he's like
maybe maybe he's into the dark arts i
was like
so she just wanted to go undercover just
to be like look how easy to sneak into
school and the principal's like all
right cool
yeah and then on the youtube video she
released she said that
she was concerned about school shootings
and how easy somebody can come in
and pretend like they're a part of that
did she get in trouble like
she got arrested at the end of the day
for yeah for trespassing
worth it was like well i guess we'll
tighten up
stuff yeah what else all right lady
so an influencer from dubai is getting
dragged online because she posted this
photo onto her instagram page i guess
she is very close to getting
to having a million followers after she
took this photo she then went back to
her seat which was
in um oh um she wasn't in business class
she was
in coach and so somebody on that fly
noticed that she did this took a photo
put it on twitter and people found out
that it was her so she's getting a lot
of backlash for
pretending that she's in business class
when she's in coach so it's actually a
mental illness
she's not had any work done right
but i don't think it's that big of a
deal i don't know
yeah it's just a good thing yeah that's
i mean
it's a little embarrassing but she ended
up going on twitter and saying that
she took multiple flights that day one
of the flights were in business another
flight she was in coach
it's just embarrassing like also why are
you embarrassed give the [ __ ] that
you're flying business yeah
yeah and also it's so little a lot of
people
who are influencers have this kind of
like content for their
to make money this is their whole thing
they're selling a fantasy
lifestyle yeah didn't powwow do that
yes he was on southwest
[Music]
i don't understand though how does she
make a living she's in dubai
i i don't understand she has a guy who
doesn't know
how do you mean how she afford those
those aren't cheap kicks
it was paying her bill
bills i don't know anything it looks
like it's legit right there
no is she a nurse i don't know how she's
making money
what else does she post to she's a
student yeah student
you know i'm just getting away oh that
makes sense she seems like a student
there
maybe she's getting yeah fashion nova
bag or that flat tummy tea bag
you know something yeah she does
something right savage
fenty brand deal she's doing some work
for a hairy guy who has a lot of money
yeah
you have to suck that old dick today
i'm still confused he's gonna make me
lick his [ __ ] today oh i mean you're
doing a little something a little
strange for that change honey you know
it's tough uh-huh
well we don't know well let her let her
[ __ ] no you're right dude
she might be a lawyer or an
international business person so i don't
know anything
i'm not mad at her anymore no no no no
she's a beautiful woman
yeah good for her man figured it out yep
figured it out
got busted trying to flex though also
who gives a [ __ ] yeah
that's what i'm saying who cares but who
watches who clicks on someone like oh
wow
first class yeah right oh this person
it just has a bunch of miles or
something right
[Laughter]
it's weird to call her out on it it's
like who gives a [ __ ]
what else you got jen this is not like
that brand new but you guys all saw this
already on news
all right the bear yeah and the girl
she looks like she's an older woman but
she's actually a 17 year old girl it's
because she's wearing a moo moo yeah
yeah i think it's obviously that weird
dress
that [ __ ] her hair cut this is pretty
gangster so i got in a fight
that beard jumps back over though too
the bear's [ __ ] she's just insane
yeah barrett's embarrassing very quickly
there's a lot of [ __ ] dogs
that's crazy so i got in a fight with my
girlfriend over this [ __ ]
because my girlfriend okay kid dynamite
my girlfriend goes what that's my
nickname for a kid
she she literally goes i would do that
for my dog and i was like
that doesn't make sense because that's
how you get eaten
tummy or ass first like people say that
till you see a real beer
you've never seen a real beer you've
ever seen a really good out of clothes
they're
terrifying yeah it's a giant thing i'm
like ah there goes [ __ ] whatever my
dog said she shouts out to them
so there goes ralph i feel like she's
crazy she's she loves her dog enough to
do that you deserve to die
i mean it's like i was so mad about it
you got if you're like oh dude like dude
imagine this
imagine this your girl is like oh
there's the bear goes to attack the
bear's like oh cool i'm going to eat you
ass
and then you see your girl like turn
around like no ah and then just the bear
just what do i have what do i do what do
you watch bro i go out and shove it now
no no absolutely then he's going to eat
your dick i mean what you do
is you get out your phone and you record
it on ig tv
no hold on that's not what i would do i
go what's the primary question in my
brain
primary questions am i tough enough to
do this with their bare no that's not
the question
primary question am i dumb enough to
think i can save my girl from getting
eaten ass first by a bear yeah the
answer is no
no unless i have a pistola nope no no no
you watch yeah you shoot her
and her misery i gotta shoot the bear
yeah that's a problem
that's a problem it's like that also you
can get another dog there's so many that
need homes
well it's like this don't you have that
old dog chin
i [ __ ] agree i do what i do for an
old dog
my dog doesn't have that much time i
don't know if he's still alive it's a
[ __ ] bear and you can't but how how
do you i'm not gonna be
sixteen you've been a great dad i know
right right bro
for a dollar situation that situation
that situation
could have gone and usually goes so bad
yeah it goes so bad i just
i didn't want her to die but i wish the
office i like to push the bear off but i
wish the bear would have got back on and
she went
honk and then her jaw
and then we have a much better video
it's it well well it's like the woman
who's they're in china they're driving
through a tiger sanctuary oh that's
starting with her husband yeah she goes
i'm out of here
the line goes what oh cool it's a
siberian tiger 700 pound cat goes well
no this is my territory yeah and then
mom goes out
the mom goes no that's my daughter god
bless mom god bless you and then the
other tiger goes
it's two for one it's two for on tuesday
it's two for one here we go
and we've already had kovitz yeah we're
gonna eat both of them yeah and guess
what
guess what husband hubby did he sat in
the car
no the husband was probably thinking
thanks tigers
this makes my life really easy
he was like i mean he probably was like
don't i mean what are you doing he's
like no please stop tiger
hey i mean
how about that mentally ill guy was like
oh i don't know if he's been today but
he's like oh look at these i'm gonna go
chill with the tiger the guy was like
i'm gonna talk to the tigers yeah it was
like who
oh fell over the side yeah and then the
tiger went oh this is cool
paul let him call him the security up
top stone rocks the tiger rocks like
those don't really hurt but i don't like
it so what i'm gonna do i'm gonna grab
this grown man
kill him instantly right and then run
off
and ran off i was like he was a stuffed
toy that guy they said that guy was
trying to commit suicide
right well he did it he was praying and
the tiger was like what are you doing
here i don't [ __ ] why are you gonna
hey what the [ __ ] are you doing here why
are you doing this and the guy was going
like this going like this going like
that yeah and ty was like i don't
understand but
you're giving me your [ __ ] back and
i'm a tiger and you're in the territory
what are you doing here he lifted him
like he was a like a stuffed
dude you killed him immediately oh yeah
thank you it's because he's like he's
like against the wall
yeah and then the tigers just [ __ ]
when they grab you here first the tiger
went like
yeah and the guy was like hit him the
tiger's like oh very cool
it's not where you want it's crazy no it
is though if you're the guy because you
die instead
quick huh you're saying no this woman
told me that who's a
big cat expert said that they have they
can feel they have a nerve in their
canines that can feel where your jugular
is so they keep adjusting their grip
until they get you
where you're pulsing and you
you die now at least it's quick though
when el tigre bites you like that though
they bite so hard that everything breaks
but you but you want everything to break
because what they like to do is take
those those talents and what they do is
dig into the side
like this yeah they open you up
they yeah have you seen them take out
like the wild boars it takes a little
bit for them to choke them out the
crocodile as it takes awhile you're
seeing like one of the cheetahs or
something or the jaguars grab the
crocodile by the neck oh yeah it just
pierced through that thickness well
that would be a jaguar against a caiman
yeah now what you'll see often in in
[ __ ]
uh uh africa is the big
nile crocs those and the kenyan crocs
those dragons
if you're if you're mister you're mr mr
leopard and you're having a little drink
at the hydration
you get taken dude you can see it you've
never seen the elephants ago um
i'm so thirsty i'm just gonna stick with
my big shoes
and then the crocodiles go well your
trunk looks like a sausage
and then they go okay and then the
elements like this
it's like a slinky oh my god yeah you
might want to watch this
watch the croc catch a cheetah now watch
how quick this is
and now you take a little sip
aware he's going to keep away from me
keep away from no get out of there get
away from me
get out of there now there's nothing to
be afraid here because dude you know
what kind of
diary oh damn i didn't see him
yeah it's a bad situation but i got it
yeah now china's fighting she's fighting
and it's over he's fighting he's trying
to fight me
look at that look at that death that's
what happens to a person but hey
sometimes
look at that small look at how small
those little cheaters are like
what the [ __ ] happened to gary
where the [ __ ] did gary go and you
wouldn't expect a [ __ ]
but even they're like what the [ __ ] was
that beyond
unfortunately we have lost uh
unfortunately
just on the edge of the water and you
see now the mom
uh she's oh it's the mom no way oh and
this is the very sad
sad part uh you can just see the
movement in the water there
where the crocodile take taken down uh
that
i've spent time in on this forest with
these guys yeah
they can see [ __ ] you can they can see
[ __ ] you would never see
they pick up on stuff like that don't
want to love the golden one
don't dip your toe in that flower with
africa it's a little bit it's a little
bit like
you've watched planet earth you've seen
i love one because what you'll do is
you'll be in a truck and you'll come
across
cheetahs and they'll be lying in the
dust they do nothing bored out of their
minds it's very rare you see them like
attacking [ __ ] but when you do it's a
real treat out here yeah
so it takes a while yeah now there's
another one with
what you got to hope is a man a wife can
argue
if you're looking for action you got to
hope there's a couple that don't like
each other you get an argument the wife
goes you know what [ __ ] this i'm going
to walk back to the yeah
to the hotel yeah now chappelle you know
what animal you got to really be careful
of though
what besides hippopotamuses what you
know what you know what
they call black death what a buffalo
it's the waterproof
though really yeah the water will flow
what are the waterproof flow yeah
what about the waterproof you know about
the buffalo h2o
[Music]
now now what they do is they just go
you're too close
you're just in my area they're huge i'm
gonna i'm gonna
stab you with my horn and then trample
you to mush they're [ __ ] huge dude
yeah and for hunters in africa like the
most scared of the
the water yeah
and i'll tell you what else you don't
want to be if you're in a boat if you're
in a [ __ ] row boat
in that water look at this oh [ __ ] and
jumped
into the water oh there's a hug
yeah so there you go amazing leaf
yeah let me see this water buffalo
what's that
boom look at that [ __ ] wow look
at that you just
always have to worry about it i've been
water buffalo africa is exhausting
it takes you can't take a break anyway
i'll tell you what sucks too is when
you're a water buffalo
or you're and you're being taken down by
a
bunch of lions you know what they do if
you're a big male
they get your your your balls and they
eat your balls while you're still and
then you bleed out papa yeah they're
gonna eat your nuts and then
follow you and your bleeding and your
butthole yeah then rip that ass
so it's a great time nature is super
friendly we're just trying to educate
you when you go to africa you know i
can't wait for that
that's a different kind of water buffalo
okay well that's a little [ __ ] made
buffalo we're talking about
the black that's still a big
[ __ ]
okay there we go that's more what i'm
talking about you don't want to [ __ ]
around with a man
okay okay okay
oh i've seen one flip a lion you ever
seen that video yeah
yeah i don't like people riding them
because it takes away from mine brian's
no but that's also not a that's not a
african that's a cow that would be an
asian water buffalo big difference
big difference between the african water
buffalo you cannot tame them
you will never ride no we want the
africans they will kill you
those asian ones are [ __ ] yeah there
it is black death
kills lion yeah they kill a lion yeah
this might be the one you're talking
about chappelle
no this isn't yeah why are they ganging
up without that line's not doing
the lion the lion was like i don't look
at this make a break for it
oh it's the lion king all over again
it's a bad sign
it is go go go line this one right yeah
this is the one i'm talking about
oh let's see what a homie comes through
they're eating a mask first
yeah i'm trying to bring them down now
these guys here here watch homie come
through here come he said i'm not having
this bubba
that's my friend and i'm gonna you gotta
and i'm gonna break your back wow
now your friend's still going to die now
your friend's going to die
yeah we're going to get stuck it's
pancake sunday
it's pancake sundae they got to flip
yeah now here's the problem though your
friend his asshole's exposed now he's
going to die from all the infections
yeah yeah that's going to be even and
then the hyenas are going to come
through it's a terrible death
africa is exhausting yeah all right jim
what else you got
all right going back to the little dogs
uh there's like a challenge on tick tock
and everywhere else
where you try to run away from your dog
to see which one it loves you which one
it loves more
it'll run after their parents or
whatever calm parents
i'm just owner kid i think a lot of uh
family tick tocks do that recently
really yeah to see which one the kid
likes more
or is more attached to it's really
whatever has candy
true and this one you can see this dog
obviously likes one parent i know it's
yeah yeah oh they always choose the
they're going to choose the guy
he's the one that's also handling it too
so i'm sure he probably takes care of
the dog
they go right for the alpha
yeah so he does that the entire video
but then this one was the funny one not
this one
this one
[Music]
he just he's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
there's nowhere to go it doesn't that's
the smart one yeah
keep watching this dog has the same
confused energy as chappelle
shepherds and stuff they'll freak out
they want to bring everybody together
they don't like when people are
apart they want everybody in a group i
had an english
sheepdog that used to hurt the guests if
you had a party he would run
around and everybody would gather them
up you wouldn't know he'd be off
everybody be pushed together what the
[ __ ] was going on he'd run around you
like that in your gasket this is when
you were a kid yeah he
was college grown men in college and
jeffrey his name was jeffrey
he would run in a circle and he heard
everybody i know right with my
girlfriend's
love she named dog jeffrey the greatest
dog of all time what kind of grown men
are like oh we better scoot in
yeah you don't realize you're doing it
right get the [ __ ] out of it as i was
going
better for you not only that sometimes
they'll nip you they'll nip you give you
a
little
like that on the old sheep hurting hey
what the [ __ ]
and jeffrey had a bad habit of giving
you a little
a little bite in the old balls he would
go
he'd go he'd get excited and he'd go go
for the
just a little front like that and that
would bring you right to the ground
ladies and gentlemen
right sounds exactly awesome very
exhausting very sweet dog
you're not training that [ __ ]
right you would let a dog loose who's
known for biting balls
yeah that's partying and never did it's
me but did you
bob i don't care all right friends if
you have like oh my god
why are we facing the face right now
like literally run everybody in a circle
you just people [ __ ] this you just don't
even realize you're like a dog
like oh my god we are awfully close
right now
what the [ __ ] oh what else you got jen
do you guys follow jamie foxhaw
not on instagram no okay i like him yeah
i like him too
i guess he's filming something and this
person this is a real person just watch
what this guy does
show you the tree all right all right
you look nervous
are you ready yeah yeah i think you're
ready
i think you're ready how creepy is that
oh [ __ ]
oh there's a lot of dancers this is like
a style of dance for a lot of
people it's just so creepy what's it
called i don't know what it's called
there's actually guys if you go to
universal studios haunted nights there's
a bunch of them
yes yeah i saw a guy doing it in the
third street promenade
there's that many people that can do
this i've seen this yeah yeah it's like
they do it all like they do
that like the beach too you know like
the those performers oh yeah
on the beach or whatever they'll do
stuff like that they're at every haunted
house now
so i saw this afternoon what's this now
how crazy is that song cause i need a
drink
something's going on oh yeah i don't
like that i know that's just
that's safe no that can't be some people
just born that way
yeah please don't brush more of a trick
your hair's almost natural
you're going pretty far i can't go that
far i wonder if he has like a special
double-jointed situation probably it's
just
you have longer tendons sometimes yeah
that's what's like something has to be
going on
where you can oh below the belt said
something
when you don't tap from a twister all
right
look at this it's [ __ ] over here i'll
just show you one more instagram post
i don't know where i saw this guy but
check this out look how he jumped ropes
hopscotch
watch how good it is i wish i could play
the music but i can't but he's going
with the beat too
damn look at this i'm sure you hear the
music that's more impressive
i think it's impressive right now it
gets bro you've never seen jump rope for
a hard like this one look at this
that's insane i just don't know how
how much patience i had to get good at
it just takes a lot of work
well he's a he's probably a breakdancer
yeah yes so this is a jump rope
i'll play with music just for this one
yeah i just thought that was insane that
was cool
all right that's dope yep i've got
another thing i have to work on
another new thing to learn brian yep
back on the road this weekend brian
we're in oklahoma
yeah yeah yes we're in oklahoma another
plane ride yeah i'm taking off this
thursday friday saturday oklahoma city
brickstown comic club david lucas
chappelle lacy myself will all
be there with jay schaab's thick ass we
have new merch that's available
only at the live show's new thick boy
tour merch
can only get it in person won't be
available online get tickets at
fatkz.com
right now oklahoma city you up i'm at
uh i'm at albany albany new york the
funny bone
june 18th and 19th with dove davidoff
then philadelphia pa
helium june 25 26 27 is one of my
favorite clubs of all time electric
and a reminder that conspiracy social
club with me and sam
tripoli is going to be exclusively on
rockfin.com we've had some [ __ ]
amazing podcasts big and hungry dropped
today
steve byrne and uh i got some other
surprises in store for y'all
okay i saw steve burn the other day i
was at hollywood in the best
steve is the [ __ ] i love that guy
yeah steve is the
he's funny as [ __ ] but he's also one of
the best people will you be chabelle
oh i'll be uh magooby's joke house in
baltimore maryland
uh july 15th through the timeoff 17 got
some time off and then just announce
it's not until august but august 26
doing a one-nighter at brea improv
which i'm pretty stoked on i love that
great that's great
it's a great headline there i've i've
only yeah i've only opened yup for you
there
good time but i love that club oh yeah
tickets for all of us fatkz.com love you
guys